>> Chairman on the Intergovernmental Battle
on climate change and also director general
of the energy and resources institute which
is a not for profit research institute headquarters
in new delhi but we have presents in several
parts of the world including North America,
Europe, Japan, Southeast Asia, and the Middle
East. And very soon we hope to be in Africa
as well. Well I'm very happy to give my views
on the Davos question. I personally think
that we are at critical juncture where we
could address the twin challengers of meeting
the energy needs of a growing population,
and also try to address the problem of climate
change by ensuring that we mitigate the emissions
of greenhouse gasses in the years ahead. And
what I would like to focus on is the very
severe and large problem that more people
around the world are facing. There are well
over a billion people on this planet who have
no access to modern forms of energy and there
for a number of them don't even know how to
get lighting once the sun goes down. Some
of them are able to burn a candle, some are
able to use a little lamp kerosene oil or
other forms of oi,l but quite apart from the
fact that those are polluting options. They're
certainly not satisfactory. And often they
turn out to be very expensive as well. So
what my institute has come up with is a set
of devices which include solar lanterns these
will over take base lanterns. As well as solar
dorrtays or flashlights if you want to call
them that and these use a led lighting systems.
The benefit of using these is theat there
are no running costs because it's solar energy
which gives you the lighting that product
needs. And what we are trying to do is promote
these on a large scale through a program that
I call lantern lighting leading lives. The
effort is to see that corporates, governments,
foundations around the world start looking
at this option and providing resources by
which poor people around the world can get
light into their lives. This would make such
a difference to them because not only would
they be able to, not only would they be able
to get lighting for their own daily uses,
but think of the benefits that young children
might get. They might actually be able to
prepare their lessons, they might be able
to read something. In several parts of the
world there's also a major challenge of adult
literary. Elderly people work in the daytime
can spend at least a little bit of time in
the evening trying to get literate. So essentially
this is a highly viable technology. Just to
give you an example a solar torch costs no
more than ten dollars, or less than eight
euros. A solar lantern cost the equivalent
of about seventy dollars, and with this set
of devices you could really take care of the
needs of the whole world. Having said so,
we need an institution arrangement because
every village where to need to deceminate
this particular technology you would have
to have a local representative, someone who
can carry out very minor repairs, not that
repairs are required with this technology.
And can also act as the source for marketing
reasons for these devices. So there is need
to create market based local institution infrastructure.
Now what I will submit is anyone that wants
information on this can get in touch on the
website of my institute, which is the energy
and resources institute. The website address
is teriin.org teriin.org. And you can get
all of the information you require on the
particular set of watchings. We're hoping
that if we are fortunate we will have the
kind of dedication that one is looking for
that in the next two to four years we might
be able to cover the entire planet and provide
those who have no means for modern lighting
systems who can get access to these technologies
and literally light our their lives. So this
is what I wanted to share with you and I hope
we can make a major beginning this year because
this would not only address the critical need
for energy as far as people in the world are
concerned but also to find a critical solution
for me to get emissions of greenhouse gasses
or potential emissions of greenhouse gasses
in the future. Thank you.